le gouvernement il a perdu 70 % de
l'opinion au bout de deux mois de
bataille
malgré son matraquage médiatique inouïe
70 % demandent le retrait du projet nous
avons maintenant plus de 80 % qui sont
solidaires des manifs que la grève des
transports s'arrête maintenant c'est les
salariés jusqu'au gardien de musée
jusqu'au danseurs de l'opéra jusqu'au
dans les ports ou bien dans les
raffineries ou bien chez auchan
c'est l'ensemble des salariés 30
millions de salariés qui sont contre
protect alors il peut toujours essayer
de le déposer au parlement
il passera pas macron ne passera pas il
faut qu'il en est aujourd'hui la
certitude grâce à la forte garder les
manifs et 106 normalement y avait une
défaite un arrêt comme les maudits mais
diallo dit si c'était le cas il serait
triste il serait pas là mais regardez
l'est on voit au bout de 45 jours que
les gens sont encore joyeux de seconde
de se battre et ça c'est le plus grand
message d'espoir que macron se
comprennent qu'ils ouvrent les yeux il
est isolé